tenemos aquí nuestro problema número 5 y
el problema número 5 tiene una figura
muy parecida a ésta y además tiene unos
ciertos puntos que voy a pintar justo
ahorita este de aquí es un punto am este
de aquí este es mi punto ve este de aquí
es mi punto c y para finalizar este de
aquí este es mi punto de bueno lo que me
pregunta este problema es lo siguiente
en la figura siguiente cuántos caminos
hay de a a d sin pasar por los puntos b
y sé si la única manera en la que puedes
moverte es hacia arriba o hacia la
derecha por las líneas de división es
decir por estas líneas amarillas y bueno
podemos contar con mucho cuidado cuántos
caminos hay desde a hasta d sin pasar
por b y c o la otra manera es quitar
todos los caminos que hayan para llegar
a b ya sé si te das cuenta por ejemplo
si yo camino por esta línea tarde o
temprano llega
o si yo subo por esta línea voy a llegar
a b por lo tanto creo que nos las
mejores líneas que tomar para no pasar
por b y por c si te das cuenta esta
línea tampoco nos va a servir bastante
porque de esta línea sale ven y de igual
manera está de esta línea se le ve por
lo tanto no son líneas que nos sirvan
ahorita vamos a hacer lo mismo para
hacer qué caminos no debemos de tomar
para encontrarnos con cm
bueno podríamos encontrarnos con cesc y
tomamos este camino o si tomamos por
ejemplo este camino tarde o temprano
llegaríamos el punto cm y de igual
manera para este camino este camino
donde sale ce y este otro camino estos
dos caminos son los caminos de dónde
sale ese es decir que todos estos que
acabo de marcar
son los caminos que no son posibles
porque me llevan o abel o hace y yo lo
que quiero es no llegar a ver ni llegar
a ser así que vamos a quitar los vamos a
borrar estos caminos que no me sirven
voy a borrar todo esto de aquí porque
estos caminos me llevan a veo hacer voy
a borrar todo esto de aquí todo esto de
aquí
vamos a borrar todo esto porque al final
estos caminos no son los que yo quiero y
vamos a ver con que me quedo con lo que
me quedo voy a pensar de tantito para
ver qué es lo que voy a hacer para
llegar para llegar desde aaa hasta de
muy bien ya tengo todo esto borrado y
ahora sí vamos a pensarlo un poquito más
si yo lo que quiero es llegar de jade
entonces date cuenta que tenemos algunos
caminos posibles por ejemplo yo me
podría subir por aquí hasta acá y
después irme de aquí hasta acá y este
sería uno de los caminos o también
podría ser el siguiente camino podría
subirme de aquí hasta acá y después de
aquí hasta acá y después de aquí hasta
acá y después volver a irme para acá y
así llegar a de aquí ya tengo dos
caminos posibles aunque también puede
hacer esto puede irme de aquí hasta acá
y después de aquí hasta acá y llegaría
otra vez a dm fíjate que solamente me
estoy moviendo a la derecha o hacia
arriba y por último tengo este camino
podría irme de aquí hasta acá y después
de aquí hasta acá y después de aquí
hasta acá y después subir
hasta de es decir que en total tenemos
solamente 4 posibles caminos y es una de
las opciones es el inciso b b tiene
solamente cuatro caminos así que está en
mis respuestas y parece ser que lo hice
bien me dice 4 y por lo tanto me hace
sentir confiado de que no tuve errores
en este problema así que mejor vamos a
ser el siguiente problema el problema
número 6 que que dice si 3 séptimos de n
es 42 am- lo voy a escribir de una forma
matemática algebraica ya desde un
principio si 3 séptimos de n es decir
por n esto es igual a 42 entonces lo que
me preguntan es cuánto vale cinco
séptimos de n cuánto vale cinco séptimos
de n y bueno hay varias formas de
resolver este problema podríamos
despejar completamente a n y de hecho es
más o menos lo que voy a hacer voy a
despejar a n multiplicando este
presión por el recíproco de 3 séptimos
por el inverso multiplicativo de 3
séptimos que es 7 tercios 7 tercios y
también de este lado voy a multiplicar
por siete tercios recuerda que hay que
hacer lo mismo de un lado que de otro de
tal manera que el 7 y el 7 que se
cancela el 3 y el 3 se cancela y me va a
quedar que n es igual a 7 tercios por 42
muy bien y podría resolver esto sin
embargo lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale cinco séptimos y entonces yo lo
puedo escribir así cinco séptimos de n
pero vale este [ __ ] de aquí por lo
tanto voy a sustituir a n de una vez
aquí y me va a quedar 5 séptimos por n
pero n vale 7 sobre 3 por 42 y esto es
lo que tengo que resolver para saber el
valor de 5 séptimos de n pero no padre y
lo que yo me di cuenta es que este y
éste se puede cancelar y solamente tengo
que hacer
por 42 entre 3 o de hecho cuánto es 42
entre 3 42 entre 3 a 14 no 30 12 es 42
exactamente entonces este y este se van
y solamente me queda 14 y 5 por 14 es lo
mismo que en 2050 que es 70 es decir que
es cinco séptimos de n
es lo mismo que 70 y es el inciso a y
está genial porque esta es una forma
bastante elegante de llegar al resultado
podríamos haber hecho esta operación sin
embargo al sustituir me di cuenta que se
eliminaban los sietes y bueno me gustó
mucho esta forma de resolverlo así que
vamos al siguiente problema el problema
número 7 el cual dice más o menos así
y estoy un poco dormido entonces creo
que después de hacer este vídeo me iré a
acostar así que vamos a ver qué pasa con
el problema número 7 y tengo una figura
entonces vamos a la figura la figura se
ve más o menos así se ve una figura
parecida a esto y después tengo unas
líneas por aquí tengo una línea por aquí
muy bien
y después tengo tengo una línea más o
menos así
y tengo otra línea más o menos así y
después tengo unas letras tengo la letra
am
tengo la letra be tengo las letras y la
letra de a b c d e y f
i efe muy bien y entonces que dice este
problema la figura siguiente muestra la
vista desde arriba de una caja cuadrada
sin tapa la cual está dividida en
secciones todas las secciones tienen la
misma altura es decir que esta distancia
es la misma que esta distancia que es la
misma que esta distancia más o menos me
quedo casi me queda perfecto todas las
secciones tienen la misma altura y las
secciones de e
efe tienen el doble de área que las
secciones a b y c es decir que esta área
es el doble que esta área de igual
manera esta de ésta y esta de ésta
y nos preguntan si lanzamos una canica
aleatoriamente a la caja para que caiga
en alguna de las secciones cuál es la
probabilidad de que caiga en la sección
f y bueno hace mucho que no resolvíamos
un problema de probabilidad así que
vamos a hacer este problema de
probabilidad que esencialmente es saber
cuál es el área total de esta caja y
compararlo con el área de esta sección
de la sección f porque lo que queremos
es la probabilidad de que caiga en la
sección f así que vamos a ponerle nombre
voy a decir que el área de esta sección
es x el área de estas secciones x y como
esta sección tienen lo mismo de área
entonces le voy a poner x también y aquí
también x muy bien mientras que éstas
tienen el doble de área por lo tanto
esta va a tener 2 x de área está también
2x y esta también 2 x de tal manera que
el área total de esta caja cuánto es
pues es x x mas x lo cual es 3 x
+ 2 x + 2 x 2 x lo cual es 6 x el área
total de esta caja es 3 x 6 x lo cual es
9 x muy bien ahora yo lo que quiero
saber es cuál es la probabilidad de que
si lanzo una canica para que al azar
caiga en la sección f entonces
esencialmente lo que tengo que calcular
es el área de la sección f el área de f
entre el área total es decir los
posibles casos el área total el área
total y bueno cuánto es esto el área de
f es 2x entonces me va a quedar 2x entre
el área total el área total es 9 x y qué
creés estas 2 x se van vámonos y me
queda solamente dos novenos
es decir la probabilidad de que la
canica caiga en la sección m es de dos
novenos no no no es el inciso en y yo lo
que quiero es la probabilidad de que
caiga en la sección f entonces la
probabilidad de que caiga la sección f
es dos novenos que por cierto es mi
inciso y lo voy a poner aquí es mi
inciso y voy a cambiar de color porque
ya estoy harto de este color de pasta
dental este azul pasta dental a mí no me
gusta mucho así que vamos a cambiar de
color y vamos a hacer aquí el problema
número 8 creo que aquí me cabe el
problema número 8 que dice lo siguiente
si a y b son números impares son números
impares cuales de las siguientes
afirmaciones me dan números impares y
tengo tres afirmaciones la primera dice
lo siguiente la primera a más 1 x d es
impar
a más 1 por b quiero ver si esto sin par
y vamos a ver si esto es cierto amazon y
lo podemos probar con cualquier número
supongamos que valga 5 y b valga 35 más
uno sería 66 por 3 lo cual es 18 y esto
nos número en par es decir que el número
1 no es cierto esto no me da un número
impar y tiene todo el sentido del mundo
porque si yo a un número impar le sumó 1
me da un número par y un número par por
lo que sea siempre me da un número par
par por impar es par y par por park
spark esto te lo puedes verificar con
mucha calma el número 2 dice a más 1 a
más 1 ya esto le voy a sumar b
y esencialmente ya sabemos que a uno
siempre es un número par porque a un
número en par le sumas uno y te da un
número par y si a este número par le
sumamos un número impar esto sí me da un
número impar lo podemos ver con este
ejemplo 5 más 1 663 es 9 y tú puedes
tomarnos de los ejemplos que tú quieras
5 10 20 ejemplos pero esencialmente la
idea es que cuando yo tengo un número
par y a este número par le sumó un
número impar siempre me va a dar un
número impar par más impares impar
palmas park spark y barman sin par spark
y ya están todos y vamos a ver lo que
dice la opción 3 y dice a más 1 es
exactamente la misma idea pero a esto le
vamos a quitar b y esto tiene una lógica
bastante similar a un número par
yo le restó un número en par y esto me
va a dar claramente un número
por ejemplo 63 esto es 3 y es un número
impar y de igual manera te puedes tomar
muchos ejemplos y la noción de esto es
que a un número impar cuando le sumas 1
se convierte en par y después a
cualquier número par si tú le quitas un
número impar me va a dar un número impar
entonces está también es impar funciona
y el 2 y el 3 forman el inciso y también
estamos en el xxi psoe y ya quedó así
que buenas noches nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo